et alors comment la russie at-elle réagi
à cette décision éléments de réponse
avec malice d'estrées correspondante à
moscou
pour la porte-parole de la diplomatie
russe cette décision de l'otan ne fait
que s'inscrire dans la volonté
manifestée depuis plusieurs années par
l'alliance de limiter le nombre de
postes de la mission russe écoutez d'un
échec et mat ortf cette mesure de l'otan
nous a étonnés mais elle n'était pas
inattendu nous avons surtout été étonné
par son arrogance
parce qu'on ne nous a rien expliqué au
niveau officiel aucune raison n'a été
donnée pourquoi cette mesure n'était pas
inattendu le fait est que le personnel
de notre mission permanente a déjà été
radicalement réduit en 2015 et 2018 il
s'agit d'une politique constante de
l'otan
apparemment il n'y aura bientôt plus
personne à bruxelles capable de
maintenir un vrai dialogue avec le
secrétariat international de l'alliance
et les états membres
maria zakharova qualifie en outre cette
décision de tout à fait absurde et
d'hypocrites au regard des récentes
déclarations de l'alliance sur la
nécessité de renouer un dialogue dans le
cadre du conseil russie otan au
thermostat c'est une vraie hypocrisie à
plusieurs reprises y compris récemment
l'otan a demandé de nommer le
représentant permanent russe à bruxelles
pour ne pas se limiter aux contacts au
niveau d'un représentant par intérim
l'impréparation de l'otan et des pays
membres à la coopération apparaît là de
manière définitive et irréfutables
dit
la porte parole du ministère russe des
affaires étrangères a par ailleurs fait
savoir que la russie adoptera des
mesures de rétorsion